[Music]
welcome to Tech news briefing it's
Friday May 19th I'm Zoe Thomas for The
Wall Street Journal
to say Elon Musk has an outsized profile
would be something of an understatement
the same can't be said for the cast of
Executives helping run his various
companies one of those key people is
Tesla's Chief Financial Officer Zach
kirkhorn kirkhorn is widely admired
according to others at the company for
his ability to navigate the demands of
his boss and execute musk's vision for
the company here's kirkhorn on the
company's first quarter earnings call
with investors I want to reiterate the
philosophy by which we're operating the
business this year our approach is to
grow volumes as quickly as possible in
both our vehicle and energy businesses
we plan to continue to invest heavily
into our future plans which include the
Cyber truck Next Generation platform
in-house cell production energy storage
business and our autonomy and AI enabled
products
and we plan to do this while keeping the
business financially healthy and
industry-leading
since kirkhorn became CFO four years ago
Tesla's value has risen from about 50
billion dollars to now more than 500
billion dollars so who is he and how did
he come to play such a key role with me
to discuss that is our Tesla reporter
Rebecca Elliott Rebecca give us some
brief background on who kirkhorn was
before he joined Tesla
a number of the folks who've been really
successful at Tesla over the years have
been there really since the early days
so kirkhorn was promoted to CFO in early
2019 but started at the company much
earlier in 2010 when Tesla was still
private and much smaller of course than
it is today
he
he was interested in cars back in
college kirkhorn was a leader on the
University of Pennsylvania's solar car
team and one of his college projects
involved redesigning a remote control
car to make it amphibious so able to
travel on land and in water you
certainly see that interest in cars and
in sustainability flowing through the
Arc of his career
burial style what do people who work
with him say it's like he's earned a
reputation over the years for
what I would describe as a firm and also
collegial management style he's one
allies throughout the organization by
serving as an intermediary of sorts
between musk and the rest of the staff
and also evidently is able to navigate
the relationship with Musk
quite well it's something that
numerous Executives over the years have
struggled with and it's an area where
based on my interviews with folks who've
worked with both of them it's an area
where kirkorn excels do we know why he's
particularly good at working with musk
by all accounts he's a financial whiz he
is an engineer by training as well which
has gone a long way in an organization
that really prizes engineering
and he's also willing to work behind the
scenes to execute musk's Vision Tesla's
a company where engineering is really
front and center and for kirkhorn to
have that background engineering
training it's allowed him to probe
issues and ask questions that people
I've
spoken to have described as being really
smart and something that you might not
be able to do if you didn't have that
Technical Training the value of Tesla
has grown significantly since dark horn
became CFO what do we know about his
role in doing that
kirkhorn has been described to me as
someone who has worked over the years
really tirelessly to make incremental
improvements he's very focused on
improving efficiency bringing costs down
simplifying Tesla's products and so all
of that is baked in to a lot of what
Tesla's done the company also has raised
a considerable amount of money under
kirkorn and a is left Tesla with really
a considerable
War chest of cash and Investments That
in addition to its level of
profitability and margins have set it up
in relatively good shape heading into
this period of economic uncertainty and
concerns about a cooling car market what
do investors make of kirkhorn and
particularly what do they make of him
since musk bought Twitter which he said
at a Tesla shareholder meeting earlier
this week had been a short-term
distraction
sure I mean as you mentioned musk's
acquisition of Twitter last year sparked
questions and concerns from Tesla
investors about musk's level of
attention to the company
Twitter
I think it's very safe to say is quite
the management Challenge and has been
time consuming and so that move of
musk's really prompted a lot more
conversation among investors about okay
who else is there at Tesla kind of
steering the ship and kirkhorn is one of
the key folks behind the scenes does
that mean that he's who they're thinking
of as a possible successor to Musk
Tesla board members have discussed her
corn as a possible successor to musk as
CEO and that's according to a person
familiar with the matter kirkhorn's name
came up ahead of a trial over musk's
compensation package at Tesla
that being said
some board members have expressed doubts
that musk would step aside in the
foreseeable future
you've mentioned kirkhorn is great at
being behind the scenes but he is
helping to build this company do we know
anything about what his vision is for
Tesla what it could become
Tesla is a company at the end of the day
that is almost
synonymous with musk in many ways and
in the conversations that I had folks
kept coming back to this point of
kirkhorn's really
been executing musk's vision for Tesla
and been doing that behind the scenes
for a while and so I think it's maybe
difficult to separate the two
all right that was our Tesla reporter
Rebecca Elliott and that's it for Tech
news briefing this week tnb's producer
is Julie Chang our supervising producer
is Melanie Roy and our executive
producer is Chris sinsley I'm your host
Zoe Thomas thanks for listening and have
a great weekend
foreign
[Music]